As expected of Yakushi's mansion,
we have all the classic dispensing tools
.  It is
possible to synthesize liquids, answers, and things with a surface
[music]
new Art materials and surfactants are
monostea Glyceryl phosphate
Evaline After synthesis
, transport to hepa Reno Edo, the main character of Kaiju Goshi
Water tanks and transport The water tank and transportation
were each warmed in two stages,
and hydrogen was added little by little during transportation to
which the emulsifier was added.  Strange preservatives
Stabilizers are added to make it uniform, so
it's
complete
[Music]
You're here with me
Oh,
Lotte always takes care of me.
Apply cream to the affected areas, and apply ointment containing
steroids
to areas with severely rough hands.
I
'll write a sentence, and
I have something to give to everyone
.